well Labor's Shadow Health secretary Wes
streeting is here with me now very good
morning to you nice to see you let's
kick off talking about that Junior
doctor strike four days walk out in
April they've announced they're
demanding a 35 pay rise is that a
reasonable demand I think the argument
for pay restoration is reasonable
they're making a reasonable argument
that their pay hasn't kept up in line
with inflation for more than a decade
but I've been honest with the BMA that
if I were the health secretary today we
just wouldn't be able to do a 35 pay
rise overnight and what I've asked them
to do is Judge labor on our record when
we were last in government we did
deliver pay Rises Fair pay Rises for NHS
staff in fact we delivered full pay
restoration and the reason we're able to
do that is because the economy was
growing and we were able to invest in
our public services and fair pay for
staff without having to hike up taxes in
the way that the conservatives have had
and that's why Labor's so committed to
getting the economy growing because if
you get the economy growing everything
else becomes so much more easier in
investing in our Public Services
bringing bills down making sure that
people's wages more than meet living
costs so that people can actually enjoy
life and have some Financial Security so
what do you make of the way that the BMA
are going about this pitching for a 35
pay rise that's seven times more than
nurses and ambulance workers have have
agreed to do you think they're going
about this the wrong way
well I think it's a sign of desperation
actually and I've been really struck um
when I've been talking to Junior doctors
on the front line
bearing in mind these are people towards
the earlier stage of their career in the
NHS they're really demoralized they're
really burnt out they are feeling the
pinch in their pockets particularly if
they're working in big cities with
living Costas Rising as they are
and so I think what we're seeing with
the junior doctors strike as we've seen
with the nurses and the ambulance
workers is a is a cry for help and I
think the best thing the government can
do is treat them with respect I think
some of the rhetoric the government have
used including in recent day since
talkers of talks broken down I think
just needs to be you know de-escalated
now get them back around the table I
think it's encouraging the BMA have said
that they're willing to compromise let's
see that compromise in practice now and
avert this strike action because coming
hot off the back of Easter weekend which
is always traditionally a pinch point
for NHS pressures I think is a genuine
risk to patient safety and that's why I
don't want these strikes to go ahead see
so you think the patient safety is at
risk partly because it's four days
straight off the back of a bank holiday
weekend yeah and I've had I've had
emails to that effect from consultants
in the NHS in in the last day or so
really concerned about these pressures I
and I'm glad you're covering this this
morning so I was really struck when the
junior doctor his last went on strike
for three days maybe it's a bit of
public fatigue maybe it's the you know
lots of lots of other things going on
the news but Junior doctor strikes are
arguably more disruptive to NHS Services
than the nurses strikes and the
paramedic strikes
um and and there were no derogations in
place um to maintain a level of cover
during the junior doctor strike so I'm
really worried about the impact on NHS
services and I really feel actually for
NHS leaders NHS managers who are trying
to maintain services and patient safety
against this really challenging backdrop
because unlike most negotiations where
you know the the hospital chief
executive would be the employer the
government's the employer in this case
the government's doing the negotiating
and poor Hospital leaders are the ones
that are left trying to pick up the
pieces keeping Services going for
patients and I really feel for them too
at the moment but you acknowledge that
labor would not be able to offer 35 no
we'd be around the table negotiating and
I asked Junior doctors you know trust us
on our record on this and we were in
this position pre-97 where people tried
pin us down on specific date specific
commitments we said then as the economic
circumstances allow we don't want to
make promises we can't keep Labor's
approaches to under promise and over
deliver I think given the lack of trust
in politics and politicians at the
moment that's the right approach so
judge us on our record we do understand
the case that Junior doctors are making
but they're going to have to bear with
us should there be a labor Government
after the next election as we get the
economy growing we'll be able to invest
in public services without hiking up
people's taxes and the way the
conservatives have okay I also want to
ask you about ofsted because they put
out a statement this morning as saying
that they're not going to be pausing
School inspections uh this in the
aftermath of the suicide of a head
teacher are they right to continue with
their school inspections well of course
my first thing I want to say is
absolutely heartbreaking case and and my
heart goes out
um to the family and to all the staff
who'll be affected by absolutely tragic
news I do think school inspections are
important they're important for
reassuring parents around school
standards they should be an important
tool for school Improvement clearly
there are challenges with the way that
inspections are conducted and we've seen
I think an outpouring of of Anger from
the teaching profession Labor's
committed to reform the way that
inspections work to take a more balanced
report card approach no doubt we'll be
Consulting with the profession in the
coming weeks and months but I do think I
think inspections are an important part
of I think they should carry on I do I
do think that ofsted has got to reflect
perhaps on on the tone and the level of
pressure that comes with inspections I
should say I've been through an offset
inspection myself as a school Governor I
I I have never felt a level of pressure
um uh in that way in terms of
accountability as as we did I certainly
as a governor didn't want to let the
school down uh Primary School in my
Borough in this case I I think that it's
the pressure I think that teachers feel
which has become unhealthy and in this
case I mean you know we don't want to
predetermine the the No Doubt The
Inquisitor will take place but but
clearly we can see from the facts
already available that the pressure of
the inspection has been a factor here
and that should give us all pause for
thought even if not pause in inspections
okay well where's treating we really
appreciate your time thanks very much
coming and chatting to us today thank
you thank you